my name is Nandita and I'm from the
anthos party management team and I'm
going to be joined shortly by my
colleague yevgenia she's from the
partner engineering team we are here
representing the entire anthos team -
thank you
our customers and partners for
collaborating with us for entrusting us
to innovate on your behalf so you can
build better functionality at a faster
pace more reliably and more consistently
for your customers you've heard
throughout the day provide different
teams on the capabilities that we're
building for you and we'll continue to
build for you so you can modernize on
anthos with confidence that you won't be
locked in but you can implement policy
and security management at scale build
once to run anywhere there is one
additional factor that we wanted to
highlight for you when you think about
what sets Google clouds and thoughts
about and it is our growing ecosystem of
partners several of them are here today
with us and will be joining us for the
reception as well we are working with a
variety of partners who are innovating
on our platform building their solutions
on our platform integrating their
solutions with anthos and extending
anthos for you we have over 40
technology partners that are working
with us to qualify their solutions to
work with anthos and this includes the
Best of Breed
of Enterprise commercial solutions as
well as open source options we're
working with a variety of platform
partners so you can make use of your
assisting hardware investments as well
as any new requirements can be satisfied
using validated solutions on anthers
that they are continuously releasing for
you
we are onboarding partners everyday that
can help you as service partners to
migrate and modernize your solutions
swiftly and successfully so if you're
wondering if you can run your favorite
third-party product or tool on anthos
the answer is yes whether you're a
developer or an operator the GCP
marketplace is your central repository
to find to deploy and use our partner
solutions our partners are offering
flexible subscription licenses and the
advantage of using the GCP marketplace
is you also get the benefit of
consolidated billing with your GTP spend
specific to anthos we have a number of
operators on kubernetes and kubernetes
apps to support you these are simple to
deploy out-of-the-box solutions that you
can deploy through automate automated
deployment templates on to your gke
clusters or your amp anthos on-prem
we've also made sure that we have
launched managed updates a feature that
helps both customers and partners manage
updates to these solutions so as a user
you get notified anytime a partner has
an updated version as a partner you
don't have to have the burden of
supporting older versions or outdated
versions and more importantly you have a
way to make sure you can launch and
release security patches application
updates to partners in a time to your
customers in a timely
manner if you're interested in taking a
look at the types of partner solutions
that are supported on anthos and if he
used the same lengths that Vig Iglesias
and team did when it comes to the
infrastructure layers we have partners
that can support you for storage
solutions be it on Prem or online you
have the choice to bring to anthos your
preferred load balancers or in responses
your preferred security and identity
solution providers when you think about
the platform layer we have the best of
breed of developer tools as well as IT
ops monitoring solutions so that you can
develop on anthos with confidence if
you're looking for application level
services beer databases Enterprise
commercial or open source you can see
the variety of options we have for you
the same holds good for analytics and
newer machine learning solutions that we
will be bringing to the GCP marketplace
to show you how you can get started in
using the GCP marketplace and our
partner solutions I'd like to invite on
stage you have Daniel and Zita alright
so I'll try to be shirt I know you're
all very tired and we're just move on to
the KP hour but let's talk a little bit
more about why we believe partners are
so important so one of the great
promises that anthos makes is to
accelerate application development
modernization more we want developers to
focus on what's important and what's
important is to bring competitive
advantages to their companies and we
realize it's impossible to do it without
our technology partners without building
a robust ecosystem of enterprise
solutions that run on AMPAS and work
with Antos so though this slide says
that we will look at GCP marketplace I
actually want to step back
and look at the user journey so you will
understand why we think it's important
to start with users and then bring
partners in could we please launch the
demo yeah I didn't want to take any
chances so we'll do it this way
so a partner in your opening talk
mentioned that retail and commercial
companies are very excited about anthos
so here you can see almost can see
alright yes you can see a demo a
recording of the application that is
running and this is the online boutique
shop it's very fun and looks pretty
simple but essentially for our retail
customers right this is their bread and
butter this is what their users see as
the end value of retail company's
products and offerings right not the
only one but one of those and when
development teams are working on
solutions like that it's it's not just
they having fun but they also have to
keep in mind things like how scalable
this application is how reliable it is
will they be able to make sure that all
their customers are happy during the
holiday season right so with that let's
look what can be under the hood of an
application like I just showed you and
we're going to launch another demo and
now we're looking at GCP console so you
can see I have actually two kubernetes
clusters one is on Prem cluster you see
cluster type anthos and the other one is
GK cluster and in fact on all of this on
a both of these clusters we see server
lists applications running and this is
the application that you saw actually
it's managed by cloud run the reason
developers could choose cloud ran
because it delivers on the promise of
scaling up and down from zero when
depending on the traffic so that kind of
serves this idea of when you have
holiday season peak and traffic cloud
run can handle that right and at the
same time
our users won't be able we'll be able to
manage their resources and make sure
they don't spend too much on the
infrastructure right so we see that
that's all great right so you will ask
me
so if Dania where's versus partners in
all of it right so the partner comes
next right so we can look at the
architectural overview here this is just
an example of all the micro services the
development team came up with and there
are communications between each other
what stands out on this diagram is a
data store component right and while
it's all fun to use open source tools
and manage them by ourselves when it
comes to building Piercy's and MVPs if
we want to run an application in
production we really want it to be
stable and robust and we want certain
guarantees that it won't fail
and choosing the right datastore
solution is a very important step so a
lot of our users will come to us and say
tell us which datastore provider should
we choose to run on top of anthos and
the answer to that is GCP marketplace
this is where our users would go to look
into into available databases so again
we look at the cluster DCP console let's
look at the marketplace we see all the
kubernetes apps let's filter and see
what sort of database solutions are
available there we see 23 results you
would see some of those listings have
managed updates available this is the
version of the app that has supports
manage updates we're scrolling down and
BC radius enterprise so let's say we
made a choice our user made a choice to
use Redis all right radius actually has
integrated billing so what we will get
out of it we will get a single unified
Antos build together with ready with
Redis so our procurement team doesn't
have to worry about it
so we look through there is plenty of
documentation available thanks to radius
Enterprise team
and here we are we're just configuring
choosing the right flavor the pricing
hitting deploy button and getting
deployed and obviously you all can go
and check out yourselves if you have GCP
account and you and you have billing
admin permissions right and here it is
applications operators deployed the
application is being deployed all right
so this is this is all the goodness that
users can get out of GCP marketplace and
by the way we actually support on-prem
deployments as well so whether you want
to deploy an application from
marketplace on cloud or on Prem it's
going to be the same experience as long
as your class to feed the requirements
for the for the application is that it
is that all that we do with partners
absolutely not
right when we talk to our users we
understand that actually adopting anthos
is a huge commitment and working on
application modernization take time so
asking users to adopt new development or
operation tools would be a big overhead
so what we want we want to meet our
customers where they are we want just to
embed Antos into existing developer and
operation workflows and make sure that
existing tools just work as fine so this
diagram is one of the good examples of a
collaboration that we had with Jeff Rock
team to build an end-to-end solution
workflow and and show our customers how
they can use their private container
registry in the hybrid cloud setup and
this is what we do with many more
customers and partners right we getting
feedback from customers user what kind
of solutions they're looking for and
bringing those to partners and working
together on that so it's not just it's
not just
diagram this is something that any user
can take and adopt any moment they want
to and another commitment that we make
not just to our customers but to our
partners is to make sure that we bring
anthos roadmap to them we're talking
about new components that we bring into
the anthos ecosystem and making sure
that those are seamlessly integrated
with them with partner products as well
one of the recent launches that we had
was cloud run for anthos our service
component and together with cloud run
Grampa's we announced an ecosystem of
more than 10 partners who now officially
support cloud run friend us out of box
but that I'm passing the ball back to
Nandita to wrap up our session thank you
[Applause]
thank you you've Kenya I hope that gave
everybody a glimpse of how easy and
simple it is to use solutions from our
partners but as yevgenia said and you
saw earlier in the day we want to take
steps further and further with our
partners so our approach to solving what
our customers and users are asking from
us is to use Google's first party
solutions and third party solutions from
our partners stitch them together so
every user every customer gets a first
party like reliable experience so you
will see more and more solution Maps
coming out from us similar to the CI CD
tooling solution sets that vacant team
showed you earlier today and if you want
to collaborate with us on building
solutions we want to work with you and
we want to hear from you so I do hope we
can continue the conversation our team
is going to be at the Google cloud booth
we're going to be here the rest of kube
con and more importantly we're going to
be on the rooftop for the party so do
come join us and talk to us about
solutions that you want to build
together with us to give you more
options
how you can stay connected with our
entire anthos team through cube con and
beyond I want to invite on stage our
group product manager Sam bit some up
[Applause]
thanks Linda that
good afternoon so closing times I guess
this is the moment you all have been
waiting for but one of the goal that we
had for this day is to help you
understand and throw a little bit better
so considering where we started in the
morning how many of you would say that
they have a better idea of hunters now
versus what was there in the morning by
the show of hands okay
looks like you know many of you still do
not know what anthers is so this next
slide is for those primarily so we have
a rooftop reception at 6:00 p.m. so join
us there all of us in all the presenters
will be there there will be more experts
so you can talk to them over drinks and
maybe not that will help you understand
the things better and if you miss that
we have a community booth you can go and
you know sign up and we'll happy to talk
to you about anthers or anything that
you want to talk and we have a booth on
the Explo for expo floor you can come
there and we can have a chat on your
table there is a ebook about service
mess please take that home that will
help you understand our service miss
better and we have a short link to
youtube video that will also be helpful
to learn more about answers please use
those resources and with that we will
love your feedback and please provide
this feedback either you can use the
Chromebook outside or use any of the
links here but before I do that or
before I wrap it up we have a winner
from the last feedback that happened
like
minutes back the winner is team thirst
if easier Praveen has the gift for there
you alright that's it thank you everyone
for joining us here today hope you had a
good time it was valuable thank you
[Applause]
you